hey guys welcome back to another video
in today's Thursday so that means we're
doing our weekly devasting recap so
let's start it so the first thing on the
list is that there's a new weekly event
today in PvP duel so get out there place
and do matches and contribute to get
your 2k steel also there's some new
weekly content for the week and it's on
emotes which I will show to you right
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
those are pretty cool I think my
favorite has to be the she go key he'll
click and then that Centuri and doing
the Tebow pose so that was kind of cool
in terms of the executions we talked
about a week and a half or two ago there
is no news on those yet but if they do
ever get leaders that we do know a date
I will let all of you know on top of
that there's going to be some new
content for season three as well I guess
some players got to like fly out so
they're studia they got tests and new
stuff out for the for like upcoming
patches and they said that there's going
to be new stuff for the game that's
going to definitely be worth it but guys
remember it's only the second round of
the second season so we still have a lot
of time before that does come so it's
not get our hopes up just yet also the
devs are working on changing the war
timer to work around upcoming outages
and patches for the game in the future
because sometimes some people complain
that they lost the faction war due to
outages of the game server and other
patches so they're going to try to fix
that as best they can
the devs also mentioned about the
quitter penalty which I talked about in
yesterday's video but just to reiterate
if you disconnected match of um
contoured record or penalty but it will
count if you quit the main menu or alt
f4 and you will get a 10-minute ban and
then the ornaments and suggestion that
we talked about in yesterday's video on
reddit is now being actually implemented
into the game if you missed the video
you can click on the annotation on the
screen you'll be taken there now you can
get caught up with the ornament
suggestion video and the patches that's
coming out today for patch 1.08 on pc
today and then counsel on next week
also the parrying is also being changed
it's not being removed but they're
working on changing to make heavies a
little bit less punishable so that
people don't so that people throw out
more heavy attacks and not have to be
worried about being parried
next up tional shinobi is getting a nerf
although then didn't exactly say what it
is exactly but it does have to deal with
his kick so that will be coming in the
next patch although I do have to admit
shinobi isn't really that hard to face
with his very small health bar I do
believe that this kick definitely needs
to be a little bit more punishable than
it is so I'm glad they did do this and
the first stages of colorblindness which
we talked about a couple weeks ago are
being introduced into the next patch
hopefully some players with
colorblindness I don't know if any of
you guys are but hopefully this will
help you play its game now
a little bit better and ranked mode is
also coming very soon and it would be
talked about and asked a couple weeks
leading up in these dead streams so I
will be sure to cover that all for you
there is no news on it yet only just
that it's coming very soon after this
Damien Roman the creative director in
the game director of for honor they got
on to unto the devasting and talked
about some of the patches these patches
were what I talked about in yesterday's
video which you can go check out like I
said annotation on the screen I'll leave
them in the description as well we did
talk about the patches it's coming today
for PC and it's coming next week for
consoles so you guys don't want to miss
that you guys might want to get caught
up to date but anyway you Ubisoft
didn't exactly specify this time as well
but warlord is going to be getting a
nerf to hits the road distance and Kenta
is finally going to be getting a buff
but like I said they never did state
what hopefully this will make Ken say
become more of a mid to top-tier hero
instead of the very bottom where he is
now which have to wait and see though
and then next up is shinobi Orochi and
conker are still being looked at and
probably aren't going to be having a
buff this patch or the next one sony
Nobu Shiro to your conne coming I feel
sorry for you guys you're just going to
have to wait a bit a little bit longer
your long awaited bucks so sorry guys
also the dev says that they're going to
be making a technical server for for
honor it's kind of like how Blizzard
does the PTR for overwatch and if you
aren't familiar for what it is
Blizzard has this thing called the PTR
which allows players for only on PC
though to test upcoming patches and look
for bugs glitches and give their
feedback on whether a certain or for
buff was necessary or not which is what
Ubisoft kind of plans to do a for honor
but using a technical server like I said
it's probably going to be only PC
players but maybe they'll find out a way
to do for counsel no clue yet and then
lastly on the list for honor the Fallen
or subreddit is going to be hosting
another tournament soon where you can
compete against other players on any
console or PC whatever you use for a
cash prize so if you want to enter keep
an eye on the reddit for the next week
or so for more information anyway guys
that's really the end of the dev streams
most of it was taken up by them talking
about the patch that we discussed
yesterday like I said some third time
this video today you can either click
the annotation or you can go in the
description click that video and get
caught up on what we talked abouts here
you know you're all caught up to date
you
you did like the video hit the like
button if you disliked it dislike button
if you're new to the channel hit the
subscribe button always putting out for
honor content for all of you guys to
enjoy
thank you all for love and support in
these past couple videos in the past a
week or so and I'll see you all later
and peace out